[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen Fall wir bleiben in der ersten
Hälfte des 20 Jahrhunderts mein Name ist
Mirko Kasimir und ich bin Toni Heyer ich
freue mich dass ihr auch heute wieder
mit dabei seid in unserer letzten
Geschichte da waren wir in den völlig
verstörten USA zurückgeblieben am 18 mai
1927 hatte ein verbitterter und aus der
Bahn geworfener Farmer namens Andrej ein
Massaker an einer Schule in Michigan
angerichtet aber nur drei Tage später
sprachen alle über Charles Lindberg und
sein Triumph denn am 21 mai gegen 10 Uhr
abends war der Pilot in Paris gelandet
für diesen offiziell ersten
nonstop-atlantikflug bekam der Mann
nicht nur Beifall und Schlagzeilen
sondern auch ein Preisgeld von 25.000
Dollar damals ein richtiges Vermögen so
kurz nach dem Massaker von bARF ist
diese Geschichte eine willkommene
Ablenkung für das aufgewählte Land und
Lindberg wird zu etwas wie dem ersten
echten Superstar des modernen Amerika
niemand ahnt dass er und seine junge
Familie bald selber für schreckliche
Schlagzeilen sorgen werden
bevor wir dazu kommen lass uns den Mann
mal näher kennenlernen Mirko mit vollem
Namen heißt er Charles agustes Lindberg
Junior und wird am 4 februar 1902 in
Detroit geboren er ist ein Einzelkind
sein Vater ist Rechtsanwalt und
Politiker seine Mutter Chemielehrerin
die Eltern lassen sich sieben Jahre nach
seiner Geburt scheiden okay Marco dass
er alles schön und gut aber noch nicht
so richtig spannend das siehst Du
hoffentlich anders wenn du mehr über die
Großväter erfährst Charles Opa
väterlicherseits oder mondson war ein
wichtiger Politiker in Schweden bis er
bei einem korruptions-skandal erwischt
wurde Monson wanderte in die USA aus und
nannte sich von nun an Lindberg
okay und weiter und sein Großvater
mütterlicherseits war der Zahnarzt
Charles Henry Land der die jacket-krone
erfand er galt deshalb auch als Vater
der Porzellan Zahnheilkunde okay also
die Opas das sind auf jeden Fall
markante Typen die Scheidung der Eltern
prägt lindbergs Teenagerjahre mal wohnt
er beim Vater in Washington mal bei der
Mutter in Kalifornien aber sein
Interesse gilt weder der Medizin noch
der Politik wie bei den Großvätern
sondern der Technik
der Vater hat ein Auto für das sich der
junge Charles begeistert später tüftelt
er an seinem eigenen Motorrad herum und
folgerichtig beginnt er dann auch ein
Maschinenbaustudium das bricht er aber
frühzeitig ab und tritt bei der Nebraska
Aircraft Corporation eine
Pilotenausbildung an den abschließenden
Alleinflug macht er aber nicht weil er
die dazu benötigte Kaution nicht
hinterlegen kann Lindberg braucht also
Geld Flug Erfahrung und am liebsten ein
eigenes Flugzeug also zieht er durch die
Lande und Job den Colorado Nebraska oder
Wyoming und zwar unter anderem als
Fallschirmspringer und
Flugzeugmechaniker
anschließend wurde eine Weile wieder
kostengünstig bei seinem Vater im Mai
1923 geht er nach Georgia um wieder auf
einem Flugzeug zu joggen und um sich
endlich vom Ersparten ein eigenes
Flugzeug zu kaufen
eine gebrauchte Maschine vom Typ j-n4
von Piloten liebevoll Jenny genannt
anschließend fängt er bei der
US-Luftwaffe eine Pilotenausbildung an
und beendet sie als Jahrgangs bester
aber weil der Bedarf an Militärpiloten
in den 1920er Jahren gering ist wird
Lindberg erstmal Postflieger auf der
Strecke sein Louis Chicago wir sind
jetzt im Jahr 1925
Charles Lindberg hat offenbar wenig
anderes im Kopf als fliegen wenn er
keine Post transportiert träumt er von
einem nonstop Flug nach Europa von New
York nach Paris dafür hat schon im Jahr
1919 Raymond ortic einen Preis
ausgesetzt
ist ein in Frankreich geborener
US-Amerikaner der mit Hotels reich
geworden ist
[Musik]
einige Piloten sind bereits an dieser
Aufgabe gescheitert der Fairness halber
sollten wir hier aber auch mal erwähnen
dass es mehrere Atlantiküberquerungen
per Flugzeug gab das haben wir in der
Recherche für diese Folge herausgefunden
also hier so ein kleiner Transparenz
Hinweis am 8 mai 1919 starten drei
Flugboote zu einer Atlantiküberquerung
von New York nach Lissabon eines kam
durch aber nicht nonstop die erste
ununterbrochene Überquerung von Amerika
nach Europa mit einem Flugzeug gelang am
14 Juni 1919 zwei Piloten namens elkok
und Witten sie schafften es nach Irland
aber eben zu zweit für Lindberg bleibt
also noch die Ehre ganz allein und nach
Paris zu fliegen um das Preisgeld zu
kassieren dabei unterstützen ihn Freunde
aus der Freimaurerloge der er angehört
er wendet sich an einen Flugzeugbauer im
kalifornischen San Diego und fragt ob
man ihm eine einmotorige Maschine für
diese Strecke bauen könnte und nach drei
Monaten ist die Auftragsarbeit fertig
ein flotterflieger mit dem Namen spirit
of send Louis das Flugzeug ist aus
Stahlrohr und Fichtenholz gebaut die mit
Kunststoff überzogen wurden es ist
achteinhalb Meter lang unter deine
Spannweite von 14 Metern die Presse
nimmt die Maschine etwas despektierlich
fliegen dafür sehen Kiste 20 Mai 1927
7:54 Uhr Lindberg startet auf dem Reset
in New York seinen Alleinflug
damit die Maschine nicht zu schwer wird
verzichtet er auf Funkgerät und Sextant
es gibt aber auch keinen Fallschirm er
muss mit Armbanduhr Landkarten und einem
Kompass navigieren die Strecke die
erschaffen will beträgt 5.800 Kilometer
an Bord hat er eine Flasche Wasser und 5
Sandwiches der Flug verläuft ohne
schwere Pannen aber natürlich nicht ganz
reibungslos gleich über dem kanadischen
Neufundland Gerät Lindberg in einen
schweren Schneesturm ein paar Stunden
wird er so müde dass er sogar einschläft
nach 22 Stunden Flug sieht er Gespenster
und nach 27 Stunden die Küstenlinie
Irlands beim letzten Stück des Flugs als
es schon wieder dunkel wird richtet er
sich nach der Beleuchtung des
Eiffelturms
und von der Triumph fallen Landung in
Paris haben wir ja schon am Anfang
dieser Episode geschwärmt Lindberg ist
jetzt ein berühmter Mann und dank dem
Preisgeld von 25000 $ auch vermögend der
heutige Wert entspricht je mehr als
400.000 Dollar Lindberg genießt sein um
er wird auf dem Balkon der US-Botschaft
in Paris genauso gefeiert wie später in
Belgien England und nach seiner Rückkehr
in den USA und das muss man auch
erwähnen um diese Zeit und lindbergs
Rolle zu verstehen
Ende der 1920er Jahre boomt dank ihm
nicht nur die Fliegerei sondern auch die
modernen Massenmedien wie das Radio und
maschinell gedruckte Zeitungen mit Platz
für große Fotos
Lindberg ist also der erste echte
Superstar seiner Zeit er wird unter
anderem Lucky Lindy genannt der
Glückspilz der Lüfte sozusagen aber er
ist noch Single obwohl er doch so eine
gute Partie abgibt natürlich dauert es
jetzt nicht mehr lange wir sind noch
immer im Jahr 1927
lindbergs Finanzberater Drive Morrow hat
ihn nach Mexiko eingeladen wo er in
diesem Zeitraum auch als Botschafter
tätig ist und auf dieser Tour lernt
Charles in Mexiko City morrows Tochter
an kennen
was für ein wunderschönes Partyband in
den Zeitungen abgeben Charles Lindberg
ist schlank sportlich hat mittelblondes
Haar und klare Gesichtszüge er hat
ausdrucksstarke Augen und kann sehr
entschlossen reinblicken und sehr
charmant und jungenhaft Grinsen scheint
wie das perfekte Gegenstück zum großen
blonden Flieger Lindberg sie ist klein
schlank schmal mit kräftigen dunklen
Haaren einer süßen Stupsnase und einem
lustigen frechen Gesichtsausdruck es
muss sofort sehr doll und nachhaltig
gefunkt haben bei den beiden denn keine
zwei Jahre später am 27 mai 1929
heiraten die beiden auf dem Anwesen von
ans Eltern in New Jersey schon bald
teilt Sie Charles Leidenschaft für das
Fliegen er bildet sie zur Piloten aus
ihr Leben lang begleitet an ihren Mann
immer wieder als Funkerin und Co-Pilot
das Idyll scheint perfekt als am 22 juni
1930 der Sohn Charles junior geboren
wird der Knirps kommt tatsächlich daher
wie eine perfekte Mischung der hübschen
Eltern Wuschelhaare wacher Blick und
Bubi Lächeln die Familie bezieht ein
Haus in hopewelle New Jersey südwestlich
von New York City das Anwesen aus Helm
Klinker das lässt sich heute noch
bewundern es hat zwei seitenfronten und
senkrecht dazu einen Mittelbau die
Dachziegel sind schwarz die Villa könnte
auch im Norden England stehen und sie
hat reichlich Platz für die drei
Lindenbergs wobei ja auch Personal
untergebracht werden muss
die lindbergs sind schließlich reiche
Leute Traumfrau Traumhaus Wunschbaby und
eine bis dahin beispiellose
Medienkarriere alles scheint perfekt
aber das große Glück des Charles
Lindberg wird am ersten märz 1932 vom
grauen einer Kindesentführung
erschüttert am Abend dieses
Frühlingstages stellt jemand eine Leiter
an die Wand des abgelegenen Hauses in
hogwell klettert ins Zimmer des kleinen
Charles und verschleppt das Kind
erstmals bemerken weder die Eltern noch
das Hauspersonal irgendetwas
verdächtiges es ist die Arme Betty Gau
der etwas später auffällt dass das
Lindberg Baby aus dem Bettchen
verschwunden ist die gelernte
Krankenschwester hatte bemerkt dass der
kleine Charles anders als gedacht nicht
bei Mutter n war die gerade ein Bad
genommen hatte also schaut die Arme im
Kinderzimmer nach als sie dort keine
Spur des Kindes entdeckt alarmiert Sie
Lindberg der Sturm zum Kinderzimmer und
entdeckt einen Brief auf der Fensterbank
Lindberg nimmt eine Waffe und durchsucht
mit dem Butler ollywodley erst das Haus
dann das Grundstück die beiden finden
die Leiter an der Wand und Fußabdrücke
in der Erde schließlich rufen Sie die
örtliche Polizei in Hopewell die
Ermittler protokollieren ist so
Charles Augustus Lindberg Junior der 20
Monate alte Sohn des berühmten Fliegers
und seine Frau an Morrow wurde am ersten
März gegen 9 Uhr Abends aus seinem
Kinderzimmer im zweiten Stock des
Elternhauses in der Nähe von Hope New
Jersey entführt
die Abwesenheit des Kindes wurde etwa
gegen 10 Uhr von der arme Betty Gau
entdeckt und den Eltern mitgeteilt bei
der sofortigen Durchsuchung des Hauses
wurde auf dem Fensterbrett im
Kinderzimmer eine Lösegeldforderung über
50.000 Dollar gefunden die
Öffentlichkeit in den USA ist außer sich
denn schließlich gilt Lucky Lindy seit
seinem atlantikflug nicht nur als Promi
sondern als nationaler Held
schnell wird die Forderung nach der
Todesstrafe laut dabei gibt es weder vom
Täter noch vom Kind eine Spur aber weil
ein Nationalheld betroffen ist handelt
die Politik schnell das Buero auf
investigation der Vorläufer des FBI
erhält die Zuständigkeit für diesen Fall
tausende Beamte im ganzen Land sind für
das Lindberg Baby im Einsatz zurück zum
Abend der Tat schon um Mitternacht
untersucht ein Fingerabdruck Experte den
Erpresserbrief weder darauf noch im
Kinderzimmer gibt es verwertbare
Abdrücke der Täter muss Handschuhe
getragen haben dafür ist der Brief umso
interessanter er wurde völlig fehlerhaft
geschrieben in krakeliger Handschrift
steht da lieber Herr haben sie 50.000
Dollar fertig
25.000 Dollar in 20 $ Scheine 15000 $ in
10 $ Scheine und 10.000 Dollar in 5 $
Scheine
nach zwei bis vier Tagen werden wir Sie
darüber informieren ob sie das Geld
liefern sollen wir warnen sie davor
irgendwas öffentlich zu machen
auf dem Blatt Papier befinden sich rote
und blaue Runde Markierungen die Polizei
ist sich sicher dass der Entführer noch
nicht lange in den USA lebt und nur
schlecht englisch spricht sie stellt
außerdem fest dass die Leiter am Haus
vom Täter selbst gebaut worden war und
zwar ziemlich fachmännisch wie bei so
vielen Entführungsfällen erweist sich
die Lösegeldübergabe als logistischer
Albtraum erstmal gibt es keine weiteren
Anweisungen im Laufe der Zeit erhalten
die Eltern dann aber insgesamt 15
Lösegeld schreiben die USA erlebt eine
Fahndungsaktion wie nie zuvor Charles
Lindberg nimmt die fieberhafte Suche
nach seinem Sohn selbst in die Hand aus
dem Gefängnis bietet sogar der Gangster
Al Capone seine Hilfe an andere
zwielichtige Figuren setzen Lindberg
absichtlich auf falsche Fährten am 6
märz trifft ein neuer Brief ein wieder
mit den farbigen Markierungen
jetzt hat sich die Forderung auf 70.000
Dollar erhöht der Brief war zwei Tage
zuvor im New Yorker Stadtteil Brooklyn
abgestempelt worden als Vermittler in
dem Fall schaltet sich schließlich der
pensionierte Lehrer John conden ein ihm
gelingt es mit dem Entführer Kontakt
aufzunehmen und per Zeitungsanzeige zu
signalisieren dass das Lösegeld
bereitsteht
zwischenzeitlich kommt es sogar zu einem
Treffen bei der Begegnung in der
Dunkelheit behauptet ein Mann der sich
John nennt er sei Teil der
entführerbande das Kind sei auf einem
Schiff und werde nach der Zahlung
freigelassen
konden fordert dass die Bande ihre
Glaubhaftigkeit mit einem Beweisstück
versichern müsse tatsächlich erhält die
Familie bald einen Schlafanzug von
Charles Junior
nach weiteren Vorbereitungen und
Verhandlungen wird schließlich am
zweiten april 1932 ein reduziertes
Lösegeld von 50.000 Dollar in einer
Holzkiste dem Mann übergeben der sich
John nennt unter den Geldscheinen sind
viele der damals üblichen
Goldzertifikate die man anhand ihrer
Seriennummern gut nachverfolgen kann der
Empfänger John wiederum reicht dem
Vermittler konden einen Zettel darauf
wird versichert in Kürze würden zwei
Frauen das Kind freilassen 70 m entfernt
beobachtet Charles Lindberg das
Geschehen mehr als einen Monat später am
12 Mai sind Lieferwagenfahrer Orwell
Wilson und sein Kollege William Alan im
Wohnbezirk der lindbergs in Hauptbahnhof
unterwegs als
Ellen an einem Waldstück pinkeln will
dabei entdeckt er die Leiche eines
Kleinkindes
schon beim ersten Blick auf den stark
verwiesen Körper sieht man dass der
Schädel des Babys eingeschlagen wurde
Charles Lindberg Junior ist tot
Arme Betty auch identifiziert den jungen
anhand seines Hemdes und einer
Fehlbildung am Füßchen
zehn Wochen nach der Entführung bringt
die New York Times die gefürchtete
Schlagzeile Baby dead die Familie ist
erschüttert Charles Lindberg besteht
darauf dass das Kind schnell
eingeäschert wird die Bundespolizei will
jetzt schnell Ermittlungserfolge liefern
und diese Hektik erweist sich als fatal
denn so gerät die britische
Hausangestellte wireless Sharp in
Verdacht sie soll bei ersten Befragungen
nach der Entführung nervös gewirkt haben
die Anschuldigungen treffen sich schwer
am 10 Juni begeht sie Selbstmord indem
sie sich mit silberpolitur vergiftet ihr
Alibi für die Tatnacht erwies sich
später als richtig es sind schließlich
die nummerierten Goldzertifikate die zum
Täter führen am 18 September 1934
bemerkt ein Bankangestellter in
Manhattan ein solches Gold Zertifikat
darauf hat jemand ein Autokennzeichen
notiert es lautet for you
thirteen forty one and
der Name ist zugelassen auf einen
gewissen Richard Hauptmann einen
vorbestraften Einwanderer aus
Deutschland der war nach einer
kriminellen Karriere in Sachsen 1923
illegal in die USA eingewandert hatte
geheiratet und als Tischler gearbeitet
der Mann wird verhaftet und in seiner
Wohnung findet die Polizei weitere Reste
des Lösegeldes eine Skizze und
holzfragmente der selbstgebauten Leiter
und die Telefonnummer von Vermittler
John Konten es kommt zum Prozess in
flemmington New Jersey die Stimmung ist
aufgeheizt vor dem Gerichtsgebäude rufen
Schaulustige kill the German der
deutsche aber besteht im Verfahren auf
seine Unschuld unter anderem erklärt er
die Herkunft der nummerierten Banknoten
mit seinem Freund isidorfisch der sie
ihm überlassen habe die Verteidigung
bemängelt außerdem dass am Tatort
keinerlei Spuren von Hauptmann gesichert
werden konnten entscheidend im Prozess
sind aber zwei Aussagen
Vermittler konnten identifiziert
Hauptmann als den Mann dem er das Geld
übergeben hatte glindberg der die Aktion
vom Auto aus beobachtet hatte gab an in
dessen Stimme die das Entführers
wiedererkannt zu haben obwohl er 70
Meter entfernt saß es gibt also
berechtigte Zweifel an der Beweiskette
gerade Hauptmanns bekannter isidorfisch
hätte eingehende Untersuchung verdient
aber der ist zurück nach Deutschland
gegangen
trotz der Zweifel und auch nach zwei
Berufungen wird Richard Hauptmann am 3
april 1936 auf dem elektrischen Stuhl
hingerichtet die lindbergs kehrten den
USA nach all dem Schrecken den Rücken
und zogen nach England sie bekamen
insgesamt noch fünf Kinder mit dem Tod
Hauptmanns war der Fall aber noch immer
nicht abgeschlossen noch Jahrzehnte
später galt seine Verurteilung als
umstritten oder sogar als Fehlurteil so
sei User mittleren isidorfisch schon ein
Jahr vor Hauptbahnhof Verhaftung
aufgefallen er hatte sich demnach mit
scheinen aus dem Lösegeld eine
Schiffskarte nach Deutschland gekauft
1961 berichtet die Athener Zeitung
Akropolis von einer ganz anderen Spur im
Nachlass eines Griechen namens
Konstantinos marathos sein etliche
Geldbündel gefunden worden die aus dem
lindberghösegeld stammen
marathos hatte zur Tatzeit nahe bei den
lindbergs gewohnt und erregte bei der
Rückkehr nach Griechenland sehr viel
Aufsehen durch hohe Geldausgaben
hauptmannswitwe Anna kämpfte bis zu
ihrem Tod 1994 für eine Rehabilitierung
ihres Mannes und zeigte Hauptmanns
Ankläger wegen falscher Anschuldigungen
an vergebens
das war's für heute wenn ihr euch jetzt
gut reingehört habt in die 1920er und
30er Jahre in den USA dann empfehlen wir
euch noch unsere Folge das perfekte
Verbrechen die beschreibt einen
unfassbaren Mord im l.a von 1924 also
wirklich eine ganz verrückte und absurde
abstruse ich weiß gar nicht wie man
zusammenfassen soll hört es euch selber
an die Geschichte vom Lindberg Baby
haben wir erzählt mit einem
ausführlichen Artikel aus der Welt einem
history-artikel des DLF sowie der Seite
Charles lindberg.com Skript Stefan Netze
Band Aufnahme und schnitt Toni heuer
brustproduktion weight watch Studios
München
vielen Dank fürs Zuhören das war's für
heute euer Mirko und eure Tour